from tvline.com emmys hits all time
audience low good wow good the end is
nigh did you watch it i i didn't even
know what happened yeah i didn't i
watched it for those of you that are
saying right now sending your chats at
super chats did you know the emmys even
happened like one or i did not know
i had no clue it was not in anyone's
feeds i mean you would see the you know
nobody was tweeting about it i watched
it because i feel like i have to watch
those kinds of things it was i'm sorry
you had to do that
there was a moment where i told my wife
adriana i'm like we can't do this she
says no no we got to keep watching
it was a cringe fest just one thing
after the other just caught it's so
infused into ev and saturated just it's
just saturated into everything that they
do the awards they give the shows they
give
shows that should have easily won were
lost out to the most woke show i mean
it's just i think it's just part of
that why the reason why those ratings
are so low that's we have such a great
opportunity right now well i kind of
think that uh
the system is collapsing
and it's more apparent uh to me than i
think to the average person for a few
reasons
i don't know if it's going to recover so
we got a bunch of times square
billboards we did this over the summer
we we went nuts we had like 25 ads just
like dominating the space was awesome
and a lot of people were like that's
crazy how could you afford that and then
i'm just like bro it costs 20 bucks to
run an ad in times square
one time yeah so like
and you can get even cheaper there's
some some smaller ads like still big
screens like seven dollars and they'll
say like you got to buy at least 20 of
them or whatever so it's a couple
hundred bucks and then it'll run for the
day
that's a lot cheaper than people realize
and the reason
you know it's done like the foot traffic
is down
these there's no impact anymore there's
no cultural references there's like
there's no cultural cohesion so even
having the ads doesn't do anything it's
just a statement being made and i
thought about it i'm like here we are we
did it we're here in the center of
american culture
and we made our point
but we were only able to because the
system has decayed to the point where
the it used to be that there's so many
big companies with tens of millions of
dollars that they were all competing for
these spaces the prices were super high
now nobody wants them now they're like
some of the billboards in there are
turned off
so so yeah off interesting and i'm like
hey that one that's off can i get that
one we ended up getting the entire
billboard to ourselves
so we also ended up hitting number two
on billboard digital sales
and you know what you know we sold
twelve thousand five hundred and twenty
songs in one week that's number two
twelve thousand interesting that's it
it's interesting it used to be
hundred two hundred five hundred
thousand sold now i i get it we're in a
different kind of economy with streaming
music
but
it's not just about uh you know nobody's
encouraging i mean you can check this
out to the rental economy and you'll own
nothing and you'll be happy but my point
is we are able to stand atop the ruins
we're able to be like look how well
we're doing only because the system has
collapsed
like if we had a show this big
10 years ago we would not be getting top
you know singles and music or times
square but because the system has just
broken down and falling apart we can
climb on the rubble and be like i am
king of the rubble and everyone's like
yeah
and then we're like ha ha
those would have gone for tens of
thousands of dollars
that you could not get out of an ad for
less than a hundred thousand dollars for
something well so like if you want to
get the biggest
the big tower you know they do it on
like a week by week basis and it's like
600 grand per week
but most of the billboards you know
they're big but they're not that big
it's like
you can have a run
all day for a couple grand and you can
actually schedule like 20 ad placements
to span over one you know one day over
you know they'll play like
once every other minute for a few hours
and it'll cost you 200 bucks
it's just that the demand is gone not
not only that but like small businesses
have been wiped out so ad revenue is
collapsing i just i look at the emmys
and it's like
american culture is being erased
these things that we used to
all
be interested in and talk about just
gone
and without that what happens you end up
i'll just say and in a big civil war
because when you have completely
disparate cultures that don't like each
other that don't care about each other
and aren't concerned about offending
each other they can say whatever they
want about each other it used to be that
you were like
okay i better not say that you know what
what's the famous apocryphal quote from
michael jordan conservatives buy shoes
too
right why don't you get uh conservatives
buy shoes too man nowadays it's like
i don't want their money anyway so i'll
rag on them and hopefully that'll make
more of the woke left by myself or the
or the inverse
now you've got democrats or republicans
refusing to debate each other
you've got uh katie hobbs she won't
debate carrie lake but you got uh who is
it hershel walker is that his name he's
not going to debate uh um warnock
warnock there you go
and so the the reality is what's to be
gained the hyper polarization is so
intense you only face risk by actually
coming together there so a republican is
going to come out and be like i'm not
going to get any of these democrat votes
why bother talking to him and the
democrats go back i'm not going to get a
republican vote why bother talking to
him because it's not even about the the
policy it's about democrats are better
or republicans are bad in which case it
is what it is the chips have fallen
where they're going to fall let's see
who wins the election
everything is fractured and it is sooner
or later
people are going to just demonize each
other to the point where they're
fighting in the streets i mean it
probably already happened it's like
already happening actually we're seeing
it i mean i don't know if it's just
because of social media that we're
seeing so much more of this kind of
violence happening or you know in los
angeles i mean
you can't go a day without seeing a
somebody walk into a restaurant while
people are eating with a gun and putting
a gun to their head and taking money
from them i think you're right the
social cohesion there is no
what event on a national scale now is
considered something that is kind of
must-see that's this cultural kind of
phenomenon that brings everybody
together even nfl even the nfl now is
broken down i mean we we the the whole
advertising thing was used to be a huge
thing where we would sit down and watch
the advertisements which advertisement
is the best and now it's just we're
constantly being bombarded with the
wokeness on these things so there's no
cohesion there's no culture and a lot of
that had to do i believe with this
illegal immigration problem that we've
been dealing with now since at least the
70s where there is no there's a there's
no entry that where people have to say
okay this is what american is and this
is what i bought into and i'm going and
i'm signing on to this i am buying into
the american
dream into the american culture into
what it means to be american we've lost
that entirely we lost it through pledge
of allegiances in schools where we used
to sing these kinds of things on a
regular basis when i was growing up now
you don't see those kinds of things
happen so much anymore that we've lost
this cultural cohesion and i think that
you're right it is leading to more and
more violence and social media is
helping instigate it and trigger it even
more the next big thing to just shatter
and destroy american culture will be
when they have
in like the nfl
and the nba force diversity when they
say stuff like hey these rules are
arbitrary why don't we mandate that half
the team be women
sooner or later
it's gonna happen
has already hit sports and the weird
left call has already hit sports sooner
or later they're gonna come out and be
like you know we made these rules up
right it's discriminatory that your team
is all male
yes then you're gonna have the nba it's
like gonna be half men and half women
and it's gonna be the sport you think
you're gonna be the one doing all the
work so much harder to get away with it
in sports i just saw another meme like
to reference you at the memes you're
talking about i saw a meme where this
woman broke the the deadlifting record
and it was
634 pounds or something and then
somebody quickly followed that up with
yeah man's of record is 1100 pounds i
mean there's so the difference between
men and women when it comes to these
kinds of things i mean and women have
their thing i prefer watching women
tennis than than men's tennis because
they're rallying it's just a little bit
more of an exciting game to watch so
there's not to say there isn't a place
for women in sports what have you but
the difference between the the sexes
when it comes to sports that's just
drastic i think the tennis thing you
know i i don't really mind i think it's
entertaining when it's like serena or
who's that other guy uh when they smash
their their racket and scream and enrage
that's what we're here for everybody
knows nobody actually enjoys watching
tennis we're just waiting for them to
smash their racket it's like i'm kidding
by the way but it's like nascar they say
that everyone's just waiting for a car
to crash or something and i'm like no
not really
you know because i i don't think that
happens all the time
but yeah man uh
so so according to this tv line article
it says
that emmy's hit the an all-time audience
low opposite the most watched monday
night football since oh nine i think i
think they're saying monday night
football right yeah
mnf yeah who was that the browns
i don't know but uh i was talking to
somebody about the state of culture and
media a while ago and they said that
sports will be the last to go
because sports is something that can't
be rerun like you can watch an old game
to see what's up but for the most part
you need the live here and now show for
what matters
with tv shows
i'm watching breaking bad right now i'm
on season five and it's it's a
ten-year-old show so much people already
seen it but but i'm like oh i'm saying
i've seen it's new to me yeah you saying
you can't we can't you can't go watch
old nfl games and be like oh like you
could i guess you were saying you
watched the emmys patrick and i was like
uh my thought was did you watch it on
1.5 speed because i have no interest but
that wouldn't mean you had to wait till
it's already done to go back and watch
we watched
we watched it live there's just no
there's no rush to the show anymore
because i'd rather watch it later faster
it just didn't it didn't represent
america and the american experience at
all and they've gone overboard you know
the whole thing with the the oscars so
white i think hollywood really took that
to heart and it honestly it felt like we
were watching the bet awards it was just
this crazy re-correction and i've talked
to
screenwriters about this the way
hollywood is they're getting fed up with
it they can't work anymore and we're
talking about very successful
showrunners of huge shows on hbo and nbc
and what have you
that they and i've been hearing this
complaint since 2012.
so this has been going on for 10 years
there where they cannot get work if
their skin is white
and so you're seeing that this this
constant infiltration in hollywood
that's why we keep going i keep going
back to the same thing
we have a great this gold rush right now
in regards to being able to get in there
and make stuff because people are dying
for it thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you